[Musique]
un bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
7-8 sport sur tv 60,18 l'émission qui
fait le tour de l'actualité sportive
yvelinoise voici le sommaire de ce lundi
15 novembre
ils seront trois clubs yvelinois au 8e
tour de la coupe de france ce dimanche
vers ça et poissy et chatou se sont
qualifiés pour la suite de la
compétition les cathos bien délocalisé à
croissy sur seine ont battu nanterre 3 2
retour sur la rencontre et sur les
autres résultats sportifs du week-end
la savate à son livre mémoires de sarah
est un récit de plusieurs années
d'expérience dans le sport de combat un
ouvrage écrit par alexandre foucher
moniteur au club d'elancourt morts par
an contre et puis l'immersion de ce sept
huit sports dans le ski à par att french
open un tournoi international de tennis
de table handisport organisé la semaine
dernière à voisins le bretonneux 26 pays
étaient représentés pendant trois jours
avec des têtes d'affiché mondial et
reste avec nous ce sera dans la deuxième
partie de cette émission c'est parti
pour le situer de sport
du football pour commencer avec cette
affaire qui secoue le pg féminin
installé à bougival dans la nuit du 4 au
5 novembre dernier la milieu de terrain
kerra hamra où il a été violemment
agressé par deux hommes à chatou l'
affaire a été révélée la semaine
dernière et les enquêteurs semblent se
diriger désormais vers la thèse du
règlement de comptes d'ordre privé est
l'un des agresseurs aurait évoqué un
homme marié avant de lui asséner
plusieurs coups de barre de fer sur les
jambes selon l'équipe d'autres joueuses
parisiennes aurait reçu également des
coups de fil anonymes quatre jours avant
les faits un homme se présentant comme
un ex de la joueuse de 31 ans elle
aurait brisé sa vie en ajoutant qu'il
allait se venger la thèse de la rivalité
sportive semble à ce stade écartée la
coéquipière d'hamra oury diallo présente
au moment des faits est retenu par l'un
des agresseurs a été placé pendant 35
heures en garde à vue finalement relâché
sans aucune charge une affaire qui a
fait trembler le paris saint-germain
sans amraoui et sans et diallo le psg
s'est lourdement inclinée ce dimanche 6
à 1 contre lyon dans la 8e journée de d1
féminine a vu la situation du club de la
capitale le club de la capitale avait
demandé le report du match qui a été
refusée par la fédération française de
football la coupe de france de football
jouait son septième acte ce week-end et
parmi les équipes les biennoises
yvelinoise engagé chatou poursuit sa
route dans la compétition succès
dimanche contre nanterre pour rejoindre
un huitième tour historique pour le club
le résumé de la rencontre avec bixente
mais rien senti steban et mathilde de
franco
ils ont tremblé jusqu'à la dernière
seconde de ce 7e tour de coupe de france
opposéà le s nantais relay chat ou
pourtant dominateurs en début de
rencontre concède le premier but un
penalty à la 31e minute qui n'aura pas
éteint les espoirs 80 on a pris un but
contre le cours du jeu
on a su revenir très vite très vite
avant la mi temps ça nous donne un peu
de force et ça je suis fier ils ont bien
réagi et on égalise on met le 2 on
pourrait même mettre 3 l'équipe parvient
à inverser la tendance pour rentrer aux
vestiaires à la mi-temps en menant de
busan dans la volonté dans la dans notre
façon de entreprendre ne pas subir la la
on compte on a été bien on a pris les
choses en main dès le début on a essayé
de jouer de thil est là nous mêmes ont
poussé par le public chatou wallemme
inscrire un troisième but cinq minutes
après la reprise avant de subir les
pressions adverses en deuxième mi-temps
on met le troisième et après on souffre
comme un vrai match de coupe quoi où les
qui prend tous les risques et nous on
est là on sait pas trop si on doit
défendre attaquer et au final ça tiens
et si c'est le charme de la coupe malgré
la réduction du score encaissé à la 67e
minute chatou tient bon et s'imposent
finalement 3 buts à 2 il accède donc au
8e tour le 27 novembre prochain aller le
plus loin possible je pense qu'au jeu
chartres qui a gagné donc objectif
faire un match correct costaud et 7
passes et le tour en cas d'exploit face
aux c# pensionnaire de nationale 2
chatou pourrait même se frotter à
l'élite du football français les clubs
de ligue 1 entre en lice au 9e tour
et j'accueille bixente mayence
santisteva de bonsoir bixente sans
rigoler dans les starting blocks pour
vous donner les résultats de nos clubs
et sportifs yvelinois après chatou
bixente deux autres club yvelinois
qualifié au 8e tour mais comme vous
l'avez dit en titre il s'agit de
versailles et poissy c'est un sans faute
puisque versa il emporté 3-2 sur la
pelouse de lumbres club du pas de calais
un scénario à suspense menait 2-1 et
versailles et sont parvenus à inverser
la tendance dans les dernières minutes
par deux buts aux 83 et 85e minute et
versailles affrontera au prochain tour
son homologue yves binois poissy qui
s'est défait de saint-julien club
normand de régionale 3 ça s'est joué sur
un fil tout le public s'attendait à voir
une séance de tirs au but c'était sans
compter sur chaque tour et qui libère
les siens à la 93e minute un club
yvelinois sera donc 9e tour
obligatoirement puisque on attend un cac
patience ce choc entre versailles et
poissy le 27 novembre prochain chatou
dont on a parlé un peu plus tôt
affrontera quant à lui le sait charte
jean pierre papin club de nationale 2
qui se situe dans la division de
versailles et poissy pour moi une bonne
nouvelle avec cette présence d'un club
yvelinois assuré au 9e tour on passe au
tennis à présent avant sa participation
en coupe davis avec l'équipe de france
arthur rinderknecht était en suède la
semaine dernière oui un beau parcours
qu'il aura emmené jusqu'aux quarts de
finale du tournoi atp 250 de stockholm
tombeur par forfait du 36e au classement
atp alexander beaubelique il s'est
ensuite défait du slovaque jozef
kowalczyk
6 4 6 1 mais en car la marche était
peut-être un peu trop haute pour notre
yvelinois 60e mondial face à lui le
canadien denis chapovalov le 18e au
classement atp qui aura quand même dû
batailler pour l'emporter après avoir
concédé le premier set au français 6-4
ils emportent les deux manches suivantes
7 6 3 7 5 chapovalov s'est incliné lui
en finale du tournoi du rugby à présent
avec l'équipe de france féminine et son
yvelinoise emilie boulard qui recevait
les blacks ferns c'est la version
féminine de la nouvelle zélande oui et
les garçons pourront s'inspirer ce
samedi 20 novembre de leurs homologues
féminines qui ont atomisé c'est le mot
les néo zélandaise six essais inscrits
dont le quatrième par emilie boulard
libinois ce qui augmenté l'écart à 26,6
score final 38 13 pour emilie boulard
c'est déjà un troisième essai en cinq
sélections box et un retour attendu sur
le ring après 15 mois d'absence pour le
boxeur de la verrière almed ahmed el
moussaoui chin victoire aux points pour
le franco marocain de 31 ans à
montpellier face à ivan lévy qui
pourtant c'était du costaud en face
puisque son adversaire estonien restait
sur quatre victoires d'affilée et un
bilan de 35 victoires pour 34 défaites
en carrière c'est donc la 34e victoire
également pour el moussaoui premier
français de la catégorie welters soit
les poids mi-moyens et 36e mondial 34
victoires dont 8 k o la date de son
prochain combat n'est pas encore
déterminée en golf on se souvient de la
saison énorme de antoine or other qui
tentait de défendre son titre à dubaï
oui il n'y est malheureusement pas
parvenus pourtant bien classés jusqu'à
la dernière journée antoine rosner
termine à la 4e place du dubaï
championship très inspiré tout au long
de la semaine il cède le dernier jour
avec notamment des difficultés sur les
trous 10 et 15 un retard malgré tout
bien rattrapé en fin de parcours sur les
trous 16 et 18 l'yvelinois a fait le job
avec deux birdies soit un coups en
dessous du par bilan à -20 et sept à
trois longueurs seulement du vainqueur
le danois joachim b handset du basket ça
jouait du côté de trappes oui la trappe
qui réagit face à l'as ptt de cambes
lors de cette 8e journée victoire large
76,60 un succès qui rassure et qui
maintient les trappistes dans la course
en tête après une défaite à bayeux la
semaine dernière deuxième derrière
levallois est à égalité de points avec
le c# chez les féminines en revanche
mauvaise nouvelle première défaite de la
saison pour l'entente le chesnay
rocancourt l'eau le chesnay versailles
oui malheureusement grégory elles seront
restés invaincus quand même pendant
cette journée le fcv s'incline à
domicile face à drum à douvres 58,61
elle reste première de ce classement de
nationale 2 et peuvent dès samedi montré
une fois de plus leur supériorité dans
la division face aux troisièmes le
saumur loire basket 49 la fin de ce tour
très complet des résultats avec du
handball oui la 7e journée de national 3
2 club yvelinois en lice et deux
déplacements où il le vésinet carrière
l'emportent 27 à 24 à guingamp plus
compliqué en revanche pour plaisir les
clés des faits 26-28 à asnières au
classement lâche lvc troisième plaisir
les clés 9e sur 12 merci bixente vous
parliez du fc versailles qualifié au 8e
tour de la coupe de france ça bouge dans
le club de la cité royale et jean luc
arribart est le nouveau directeur
général du fcv 78 le consultant ancien
joueur de rennes et de nancy avec une
brève expérience aussi comme directeur
sportif du rc lens a été nommé par les
nouveaux investisseurs du club une
société par actions a été créée
également pour accompagner le
développement de l'équipe première
présidée par le promoteur fille du sim
city et jean luc arribart a pour mission
de consolider l'organisation actuelle et
d'envisager une montée en puissance est
du club en collaboration étroite avec
l'entraîneur indique un communiqué une
annonce qui fait suite on vous en
parlait la semaine dernière à la
démission de daniel voisin qui a été le
président du fc versailles depuis qui
était le président du fc versailles
depuis 2004 le beach tennis fait son
apparition sur l'île de loisirs de saint
quentin en yvelines les adeptes de ce
sport peuvent désormais s'affronter sur
le sable à l'espace événementiel grâce à
une association c'est paris ouest beach
tennis le terrain a été inauguré samedi
dernier
mathilde franco et mélanie poquet
les pieds dans le sable le beach tennis
se pratique en général en duo mixte ou
non mixtes sur un terrain de beach
volley avec un filet à 1 mètre 70
1 m 82 auteur parapentiste donc
effectivement on est sur le sable donc
là pas de rebond possible on joue avec
des balles qui ressemble à bâle de mini
tennis et on a dit raquette voilà en
carbone fibre de verre qui font à peu
près 350 g c'est très physique où est
sûre long terme c'est quand même
physique en et sur le sable le
déplacement et quand même particulier ce
qui est génial c'est qu'on arrive aussi
à des plongeons quand on est en
difficulté
l'association paris ouest beach tennis
existe depuis février 2021 et compte
aujourd'hui une trentaine de licenciés
les membres de l'association cherchait
un lieu plus grand et à proximité pour
pratiquer ce sport c'est dur de trouver
des terrains aujourd'hui on a un seul
terrain qui est située sur moto donc du
côté de deux sèvres et on le partage
avec le beach volley donc aujourd'hui on
est trente adhérents partagent avec le
beach volley autant dire que les
créneaux sont très difficiles à trouver
et ce qui est vraiment frustrant c'est
qu'on peut pas jouer tous ensemble comme
aujourd'hui les terrains de beach tennis
n'étant pas encore aux normes ces
derniers seront bientôt agrandi à terme
l'association espère voir la
construction de quatre terrains
homologués pour pouvoir organiser des
tournois et des événements les terrains
l'avons été mis à disposition
au travers d'une convention d'occupation
avec une transformation qui arrivera
sous peu puisque pour que les terrains
soient aux normes ils ont besoin d'être
légèrement agrandie par rapport à la
taille qu'ils ont la taille existantes
le beach tennis peut se pratiquer tout
au long de l'année été comme hiver
l'adhésion est de 60 euros pour l'année
et la licence pour la fédération
française de tennis est à 30 euros
un livre sur un sport de combat c'est la
savate il vient de paraître c'est écrit
par alexandre foucher qui est moniteur
de savater long cours est mort palau
récit sur ses années d'expérience dans
ce sport avec ce reportage de michael et
miseront
moniteur de savate et maintenant
écrivain alexandre foucher du club de
boxe française savate d'elancourt
maurepas vient de publier un livre
baptisé mémoire de savate un récit
descriptif sur lequel il a travaillé
pendant neuf mois
le sportif y raconte son amour pour ce
sport et son expérience au sein du club
yvelinois
comme un besoin d'écrire ce livre de
raconter un petit peu l'expérience que
j'ai vécue que j'ai apprise en prenant
en charge ce club et en essayant avec
nos moyens de justement créer une
activité le mettre beaucoup plus
présents au sein des ville d'elancourt
et de maurepas et on fait tout ce
témoignage la finissait par créer une
certaine richesse et je quelque part
peut-être que j'avais peur qu'on
m'oublie les 150 pages de ce livre a
également pour vocation de changer les
mentalités sur la savate une discipline
qui compte plus de cinquante mille
licenciés en france l'objectif c'est
aussi montrer l'état d'esprit de la
savatte qui est plus qu
on a souvent une idée de la boxe de
quelque chose de cogneurs de quelque
chose de changé dirait qu'ils
réfléchissent pas et qui est et qui
fonce dans le tas je pense que c'est une
mauvaise opinion qu'on a sur l'ensemble
des sports de combat et particulièrement
sur la savate qui se veut éducative et
esthétique qui se veut aussi éthique et
tous ces valeurs là j'ai voulu les faire
rentrer dans le club le livre
d'alexandre touchette a retrouvé sur les
plateformes de vente en ligne peut être
également commandé dans les libres et
des yvelines le tarif est de 12 euros et
puis comme chaque lundi votre séquence
immersion la semaine dernière un tournoi
international handisport de tennis de
table se tenait à voisins le bretonneux
au ski par att french open 26 pays
étaient représentés pendant trois jours
avec des têtes d'affiché mondiale
michael et demi d'euros et bixente
merrien santisteva nous y emmène
[Musique]
aujourd'hui tv77 au sky par att un
tournoi de tennis de table handisport
international
c'est parti
[Musique]
pour nous présenter cet événement je
suis aux côtés de pascal dubois alors
aujourd'hui comment ça se passe pascal
écouter ça se passe on ne peut mieux on
est absolument impressionné par la
disponibilité de toutes les équipes qui
sont avec nous tant pour l'organisation
que pour les joueurs et il y à un
événement absolument incroyable qui est
en train de se passer aujourd'hui à
saint quentin en yvelines
est-ce que cet événement répond à vos
attentes ans et vous avez beaucoup
travaillé sur ce projet depuis deux
voire trois ans tout simplement est ce
que vous êtes satisfait du rendu 26
délégations quand même 26 pays un des
cinq continents qui sont avec nous
aujourd'hui et pour ces trois jours on
n'a jamais vu ça des événements
paralympiques comme ça au niveau
international sont plutôt rares en
europe et en l'organisant en cette
période post co vide c'est pas du tout
une évidence et on a cette chance là 150
joueurs quand même qu'ils sont là ce qui
est intéressant aussi c'est qu'ici il y
à toutes les formes de handicap oui tout
à fait alors en tennis de table il ya
onze classes différentes il faut bien
comprendre que selon que nous sommes en
fauteuil ou que nous avons un déficit
mental il se passe pas du tout la même
chose derrière une table entre 11
classes différentes qui permettent de
répartir ses joueurs de façon à
équilibrer un petit peu les compétitions
et c'est assez rare de la voir dans la
même compétition si je comprends bien
alors effectivement le handicap moteur
le handicap mental n'est pas toujours
associé aujourd'hui c'est un tournoi
international avec l'ensemble donc de
ces catégories qui permettent à tous les
joueurs de venir s'affronter c'est quoi
votre plus grand rêve pour skipping
alors le plus grand rêve pour skipping
ce serait d'organiser des championnats
comme celui ci
au niveau mondial pourquoi pas si ce
serait si c'était possible à écouter
avec plaisir au niveau valide aussi
pourquoi pas et puis faire en sorte de
rayonner aussi haut niveau au niveau
sportif on a quand même une équipe
masculine en national et on a des
joueurs là haut niveau en dix qui sont
classés dans l'est
vingt meilleurs mondiaux quand même au
niveau masculin et au niveau féminin
donc l'idée c'est évidemment de
développer la compétition le niveau et
peut-être aussi de faire découvrir le
tennis de table aussi bien du côté
valide que du côté handicap au plus de
monde possible et cette manifestation
s'inscrit également sur un territoire
qui va organiser les jeux olympiques les
jeux paralympiques également est ce que
c'est important de montrer aussi que le
territoire est à la hauteur de cet
événement pour les jo de 2024 et
paralympiques de 2012 oui oui parce que
ce saint quentin en yvelines est une
terre d'innovation mais une terre
d'innovation ça peut se décliner sur
beaucoup de thèmes différents au niveau
sportif on démontre qu'ils aient
effectivement on est une terre
d'innovation et que des associations
peuvent à la force de leur
personnel bénévole être capable
d'organiser des choses comme ça donc
faire en sorte effectivement que nous
puissions déployés au sein du territoire
puisque nous mêmes en tant que skip hing
on est une force du territoire bien sûr
bien sûr et on peut continuer à le faire
et on peut faire en sorte de porter les
couleurs de saint quentin en yvelines
évidemment bien plus haut et pour les
jeux olympiques je pense que les
organisateurs des jeux vont aussi
s'apercevoir qu'il ya quelque chose qui
se passe de l'autre côté donc ils
pourront peut-être aussi nous faire
confiance il ya également beaucoup de
scolaires qui sont présents ici lors de
cette première journée qui reviendront
également jeudi des scolaires du
territoire de 51 divine là aussi c'est
important j'imagine de leur montrer ce
qu'est une compétition comme celle là
alors c'est quelque chose dont nous
sommes particulièrement fiers aussi
l'objectif dont je vous parlais tout à
l'heure c'est de faire en sorte que le
sport andy puisse être davantage connue
est donc valorisé quand des jeunes
viennent comme ça il ya 22 classes qui
viennent de quasiment toutes les
établissements de la de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines 17 villes de
la commune quand des jeunes viennent
leur regard du coût change sur le
handicap et sur leur capacité quand ils
seront plus grands à faire en sorte
d'accueillir la diversité donc pour eux
on a imaginé
d un événement et des parcours qui leur
permet de voir les matches mais aussi de
se mettre à pré en situation où on a une
partie qui leur est dédié avec des
parcours jeux wii peuvent se mettre en
fauteuil par exemple essayer de jouer
avec un fauteuil pour voilà pour voir ce
que ça donne donc on est au delà de la
compréhension mental on est vraiment
dans l'expérimentation physique de ce
qu'est le handicap et on est sûr que ces
gens là toute leur vie en fait vont
garder cette ce souvenir là et donc voit
porter un regard différent sur le
handicap et sur la diversité ça aussi
c'est un motif de fierté dernière
question il ya des membres du club de
ski pin qui sont présents ici qui vont
concourir pendant ces trois jours de
compétition
un mot sur leur niveau alors vous avez
vous avez raison il ya cinq joueurs qui
quittent qui sont ici en compétition et
dans ces cinq joueurs il y en a deux qui
sont dans les 20 meilleurs mondiaux dans
leur catégorie le deuxième français est
la deuxième française dans sa catégorie
donc ces personnes là qui participent
vont porter les couleurs évidemment de
la france au niveau international mais
il faut aussi se rendre compte que dans
les cinq il y à une personne de notre
club qui handicape et qui n'est pas du
tout très très bien classé mais qui fait
l'expérience de vivre cette compétition
de très haut niveau pour participer et
pour faire en sorte de porter ces
couleurs là de façon positive et auprès
de tout le monde merci beaucoup
justement on va aller les rencontrer
dans quelques instants
[Musique]
parmi les joueurs de ski pin il y aille
au rhic alors yorick comment ça se passe
pour toi sur ce tournoi bah écoute ça se
passe vraiment super je te cache pas que
c'est parce que je fais partie du club
même temps je fais partie du club c'est
vraiment super l'organisation génial et
puis moi ça fait six ans que celui-ci
est de voir autant de monde ici autant
de fauteuil roulant je te cache pas que
ça fait un peu flipper au départ mais
mais ça fait vraiment plaisir parce
qu'il ya une vraie connexion entre
toutes les toutes les délégations et
l'organisation et hop enfin vraiment ils
sont tous au taquet l'aller les
associatives associatif et c'était
vraiment génial donc pourvu que ça dure
voilà le niveau des commandes du coup tu
as pu faire quelques matches a pour
l'instant le niveau et comment
franchement le point de monter mais
c'est assez simple dans premier match je
joue contre une tête de série n 25 qui
étaient 25 mondial je gagne 3
c'est très tactique et il valait donc
c'est un bon c'était un bon match voilà
comme je suis dit il ya d'autres matches
à venir je continue à me concentrer et
puis garder sa sortir de poule premier
et puis arrivé tu m'a posé la question
juste avant qu'on fasse tourner ton
objectif c'est pau abbas et la première
place un jeu pas d'y aller elle six
numéros sinon je vais j'ai premier
premier objectif premier si je suis pas
premier à les premiers ex-aequo si je
suis à mon ex aequo je me casse pas de
nom sinon deux podiums podium ce serait
idéal une médaille pour la france c'est
l'idéal maintenant la première mais toi
tu es dans quelle catégorie du coup j'en
castro atlas iii c'est c'est à 1 2 3 4 5
et moi je classe iii dont j'ai pas les
abdominaux donc voilà je joue beaucoup
de classe 3 et
l' objectif d'être le premier casse
trois français et mondial et le club
skipping s qui t'aident ou pas à
progresser d'année en année ce qui
t'entoure bien pour atteindre des
objectifs assez l'objectif au 605 du
coup on en revient au fait qu'ils soient
au taquet dans la prise en charge c'est
des gens qui les encadrent vachement
bien le handisport et au tennis de table
surtout essentiellement d'ailleurs ils
ont vraiment toutes les ficelles et nous
amène à nous surpasser pour pour
techniquement physiquement mentalement
qu'on soit là à l'instant t comme je te
le dis c'est des jeunes qui ont compris
l'association ski pin et en main et
c'est ils en veulent et on en veut tout
ça la table et c'est ça qui génère un
petit peu cette motivation qui fait que
ben j'espère intégrer à la première
place c'est pas fini apparemment ils
veulent faire gros c'est encore plus le
club ça va dans le bon sens bien sûr
bien sûr alors ils sont en train de
monter un pôles un pôle haut niveau et
c'est pareil son compte face une
première en france et l'objectif c'est
de réunir un maximum dans le 10sport pas
que les classements les personnes 2 3 4
5 jusqu'à jusqu'à 10,1 parce qu'après le
5/7 6-7 8 à 10 les gens sont debout avec
dix autres handicaps et l'objectif c'est
d'accueillir même les délégations
internationales donc étrangères et puis
d'essayer de les faire venir ici pour
différents stages différente
des matches ça peut être des ddd des
phases match et ça peut être en règle
générale je crois qu'il veut faire c'est
vraiment proposer des stages de l'ordre
d'une semaine plusieurs fois dans
l'année avec comme jeter les 10 des
délégations étrangères et avec le stade
français est de réunir un maximum de
monde autour de long 10 sport le fait
que ce soit à domicile pour toi ça
change quelque chose ou pas vraiment
finalement pas déjà niveau billets
d'avion c'est beaucoup moins cher je te
cache pas
j'en ai la place du coup du coup non non
c'est pour moi c'est idéal après je te
cache pas que moi je suis à paris 10
centre de paris perso j'ai quand même à
1h15 1h30 donc j'ai quand même pris
l'hôtel comme les autres mais c'est
quand même la casse est donc je te cache
pas comme ici c'est je vois là il ya les
membres du club là j'ai fait mon premier
match à tout le monde qu'elle a avec les
banderoles je viens à la fin du tournoi
et youri qui est reparti avec une
médaille d'or autour du cou dans la
catégorie kas 3
[Musique]
je suis aux côtés d'une autre athlète du
club skipping lucie alors lucic comment
s'est passé ton premier match alors
j'étais un peu stressé parce que bah je
vais à domicile donc à la fois c'est
génial je connais tout le monde mais il
faut rester focus dans la compet et
faut y aller match après match
tu vois là c'est une grosse compétition
pour toi
non par contre c'est un challenge parce
que savoir gérer la pression malgré
qu'ils aient beaucoup de gens que je
connaisse c'est un gros tournoi pour le
club ce tournoi là pendant ces trois
jours alors c'est une première on n'a
pas fait de tournée en france depuis
2014 où ça s'était pas très bien passé
et en fait avec paris 2024 on devait
faire un tournoi en france et là c'est
si on va dire un des premiers tournois
sachant que je pense que si ça se passe
très bien les gens voudront venir et là
il n'ya pas il ya des très très bon
joueur mais y'a pas tous les meilleurs
joueurs il ya encore beaucoup de femmes
on sort aussi un peu des jeux de tokyo
du coup il ya certes un chapeau qui
sortent pas pendant trois quatre mois
par exemple et qu'il faut une petite
pause avant de repartir à fond pour
parler de 1024 par exemple et aussi le
fait que voisins le bretonneux ce soir à
côté de paris ça attire aussi parce que
ben paris c'est magique caution mais
pour le voisin le bretonneux aussi tu
fais partie du club des têtes d'affiché
de ce club quels sont les objectifs à
toi sur les prochaines années les
prochains mois
montez dans la routine participer aux
championnats du monde seniors et balais
je te parie tout simplement être
championne paralympique de makati
comment on fait pour arriver aux jeux de
paris en 2024 alors moi j'ai beaucoup
d'adaptation je serais ce que m'a déjà
la mairie nous pas cela nous donne
forcément une salle pour pour
s'entraîner avec geoffrey ce soit en
cours individuels ou en cours collectif
je m'entraîne beaucoup avec les valides
et pas beaucoup avec les uns avec le
sport geoffrey fait aussi énormément de
choses
on a construit en fait ensemble tout un
projet c'est une équipe autour de moi
pour que ce soit au niveau de la
nutrition au niveau de la kiné au niveau
des os théo
préparateur mental préparateur physique
commence à gérer une compétition par
exemple savoir qu'il ya des gens qui
nous regardent comment on arrive à être
dans la bulle tout en étant bien et tout
en sachant que menez regarder
et aussi je suis étudiante en staps or
c'est donc fac de sports à paris saclay
et je fais mes années en deux ans
pourtant de faire un ou deux ans deux
entraînements par jour
alors ça peut être de la préparation
mentale de la préparation physique des
séances de tennis de table de la kiné
aussi etc etc les jeux paralympiques en
2024 à paris c'est un rêve rousset
clairement accessible pour toi à ton
avis non je mens accessible je dirais
même en plus en 2022
il ya
il y aura de nouveau règlement qui font
que ne pourra pas faire une médaille
mais si on qu'on peut essayer de se
qualifier dans trois tableaux et à table
il ya le simple le double mixte et le
double dames et ce sera quoi ton
programme pour les prochaines semaines
aulas vous m'ont demandé trop
bas en fait cela je sais mon dernier
tournoi pour 2021
après moi faut aussi que je me concentre
sur mes partiels mais je vais quand même
perdre deux soeurs entraînements par
jour j'ai quelques interventions à faire
dans les entreprises que ce soit pour
sensibiliser au niveau de handicap au
niveau du sport de haut niveau ou en
tant que féminine c'est l'e3 le 3 sont
bien voilà merci beaucoup lui si et
peut-être rendez vous jo de 2024 à paris
après une journée de compétition intense
celui ci a remporté une médaille
d'argent dans la catégorie class 8
ce tournoi en dispenser donc déroulée ce
mardi 9 novembre ce mercredi 10 novembre
mais ce jeudi 11 novembre le club
skipping espère pouvoir organiser de
nouveau ce type de tournoi à l'avenir si
vous voulez plus de renseignements sur
la structure rendez vous sur leur site
internet
mickaël millero que vous retrouverez
retrouverez voilà j'en perds mon latin
dès la semaine prochaine dès lundi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro du 7-8
sport et voilà c'est la fin de cette
émission merci votre fidélité excellente
semaine sportive sur tv 78
[Musique]
oui